[Musica]
in realtà volevamo fare una cosa cioè
far diventare la presentazione più lunga
di uno speech però non ci siamo non ci
siamo riusciti quasi Buonasera Buonasera
a tutti ciao a tutti Allora io volevo
parlarvi di un'altra cosa e però ad un
certo punto mi sono accadute delle cose
nelle ultime ore che mi hanno portato a
volgere il discorso su un tema
principale che è il desiderio desiderare
che non è retorica Ecco il desiderio è
quella cosa che mi spinge in avanti una
persona una volta mi ha detto Stai
attento a quello che desideri perché
potrebbe accadere e quindi ho desiderato
di fare il Festival di Sanremo e ho
fatto il Festival di Sanremo
desideravo fortemente di giocare con
Alessandro Del Piero ho giocato con
Alessandro Del Piero davanti ad un
pubblico di 30.000 persone
e questo è sempre stato un problema per
me perché da bambino non riuscivo cioè
desideravo delle cose ma non riuscivo a
prenderle quindi ad un certo punto ho
trovato il mio modo per prenderle Ma che
significa desiderare desiderare è quel
sentimento appassionato
che
ci allontana dalla meta da quella cosa
che ci appaga e che cos'è che ci appaga
il successo e che cos'è il successo una
cosa che è successa che non ha grande
significato perché è già accaduta Quindi
qual è la cosa più importante è il
percorso è esattamente quello che c'è in
mezzo tra il desiderare e la meta
nelle ultime ore sono Sono venuto sono
venuto qui domani avrei dovuto fare una
una serata con drusilla a Poggibonsi è
stata male non farò questa serata Non
farò questa serata Eppure sono venuto
qui in moto e ho vissuto
una Toscana meravigliosa tra le curve e
poi nascono tante altre cose quindi
Che cos'è che c'è in mezzo c'è la
creatività Ecco la creatività è molto
più importante
dell'obiettivo
e poi c'è ovviamente il pericolo c'è il
cadere c'è il perdere la concentrazione
in mezzo c'è il disastro
il mio primo ad un certo punto ho
pensato e volevo e avevo voglia di una
barca ma non avevo né i soldi per
comprarla nel pretesto
e quindi mi sono inventato un festival
musicale che si fa in barca ad un certo
punto ho detto voglio fare un mio
festival in Puglia con la barca Ma come
si fa Da dove comincio Mi serve una
barca o semplicemente fatto una cosa
normale Ho chiamato tutti i cantieri
navali chiedendo di regalarmi
una barca quindi ho viaggiato in giro
per l'Italia chiedendo una barca anche
in prestito per qualche mese ad un certo
punto ovviamente mi hanno detto tutti no
ma ad un certo punto un signore che è di
fatto vendeva automobili mi ha comprato
una barca
ve lo giuro Sono molto convincente mi ha
comprato una barca per fare il mio
festival che si chiama porto Rubino
festival che celebra il mare che faccio
in Puglia già da quattro anni sono
venuti artisti importantissimi da
mahmood vinicione Negramaro Benjamin
clements in tantissimi è cresciuto siamo
arrivati addirittura in RAI e è stato un
programma televisivo per Rai 2 l'anno
scorso siamo stati alla festa del cinema
di Roma ma in mezzo Che cosa c'è il
disastro perché poi quando compri una
barca la devi mantenere perché poi io ho
dovuto prendere la patente nautica
perché poi ad un certo punto sono non
come si fa a fare un festival in barca
quindi ho preso la mia barca Sono
arrivato a Polignano a Mare ho
attraccato Senza un minimo di permesso
iniziato a suonare e ovviamente è
arrivata la Guardia Costiera
Però per fortuna da noi in Puglia ci
sono delle cose che funzionano come dire
Vabbè dai questa volta ti faccio suonare
però la prossima volta
e quindi non mi sono beccato la multa ma
la volta dopo
prima di fare il festival Sono andato
dalla guardia costiera dalla Capitaneria
e pian piano pian piano il festival è
cresciuto Come funziona a Porto Rubino
porto Rubino ovviamente si fa su una
barca adesso è diventato un Veliero che
costeggia tutta la Puglia di solito dal
mare Adriatico al mar Ionio ci fermiamo
in alcuni porti salgono sulla sul Caicco
alcuni amici e suonano e cantano il mare
quindi io sono partito Però all'inizio
partivo da solo sono partito con la mia
barca e ad un certo punto all'altezza
del porto di Frigole dopo aver fatto una
serata al buio sono naufragato
sono finito su una secca proprio con la
barca di notte e mi sono venuti a
recuperare quelli della Guardia Costiera
alle tre del mattino
e sono finito anche sui giornali per
fortuna non hanno messo non hanno messo
il mio nome
ed è stato un'esperienza incredibile
Questa cosa purtroppo non è finita sul
documentario perché le telecamere mi
aspettavano ad Otranto e mi hanno detto
No ragazzi Voi andate avanti in macchina
io arrivo arrivo in barca non sono mai
arrivato e nel documentario abbiamo
dovuto ad un certo punto trovare il modo
di raccontare
questo naufragio che è stato raccontato
così
Kronos il tempo non è dalla nostra parte
a fretta e io con lui devo ripartire e
arrivare in serata a Otranto Ma i pirati
mi hanno messo in guardia rispetto ai
Capricci di euro Maestrale il suo figlio
più vi racconto frusta il mare Caira
nascerà e il mostro genera un mostro
mentre seduzione cerca di mettere pace
ma non è il suo mestiere
anche le onde si ribellano maestrale e
si ingrossano
tra Mario in difficoltà non riesco a
tenere il mare il motore perde potenza
cerco di tenere la prua ma il mare
scalcia e Sprigiona la sua forza succede
quello che non avrei voluto
il cuore stanco di tramari perde forza e
si spegne poi un rumore fortissimo come
un fulmine ma da sotto la pancia della
Barca prendo una cima la leggo in vita e
mi tuffo cercando di disincagliare la
barca
[Musica]
edò a rendere sono solo e ho paura
chiamo soccorso e solo dopo sei ore al
buio e in balia delle onde vengo tratto
in salvo
ma devo abbandonare tra Mari gli umani
chiamano questo incubo naufragio
sono naufragato
[Musica]
che fa sempre tramontare
posso pure uscire ma non è che posso
fare con le reti
non riusciamo mai a esco la notte alle
3:00 e poi torno un tecnico di ascensore
che quando esce il sole comincia a
tirare
poi la scoperta tra Mari era stata
avvistata in mare e recuperata da alcuni
pirati del posto il rapporto di frivole
non era persa
non venite andando sempre a tre metri
d'acqua come ho detto d'acqua
all'organico
ce ne sono delle Secche che non puoi
andare sottoposta
e vanno a finire questo è stata facile
recuperare
ci sono ancora tante miglia da fare
prima di arrivare a Taranto ma tremari è
stata ferita in battaglia e proprio non
ce la fa prima di lasciarla al suo
capezzale e sussurrato di non
preoccuparsi di riposarsi che
sicuramente ci saremo visti prima della
fine di questa storia
comincio a conoscere la generosità della
gente di mare un passaggio lo troverò di
certo
non si lascia nessuno in balia degli
eventi nessuno È un'antica legge del
mare e segna la differenza tra uomo e
bestia
In sostanza Questo è un pezzo tratto dal
film porto Rubino che trovate ancora su
Now tv su Sky Insomma on demand e ad un
certo punto sono veramente naufragato
e delle persone dei Pescatori del luogo
hanno sequestrato la barca e mi hanno
chiesto un riscatto In sostanza e quindi
abbiamo trasformato questa cosa in una
cosa un po' poetica narrata in maniera
carina quindi oggi faccio il mio
festival che è meraviglioso uno dei
festival più importanti che ci sono in
Italia si fa in Puglia o una barca
è tutto meraviglioso ma in mezzo c'è
l'imprevisto e l'imprevisto va
combattuto o in qualche modo va
acchiappato e reso anche lui celebre e
meraviglioso quindi
Amate in qualche modo i vostri
imprevisti tutto qua
Poi ad un certo punto mi sono detto Ok
faccio il mio festival ma devo iniziare
da dove inizio ero a Milano durante il
covip da dove inizio come comincio
secondo me c'è bisogno di una sigla
quindi la prima cosa che ho fatto per
porto Rubino è una sigla che fa così
[Musica]
vento
spingere
ma
Sottovento su lui
consumando che tagliano la pelle
e raffreddandomi
sogno di rientrare
spingesca rossa
[Musica]
tu la
blu scaldo il mio cuore
se vedo te
portano via
puoi anche guardare
[Musica]
Portami a casa
finché
ci sarà
la voce del mare
che da lontano
ma
Gia
porto Romeo
vuoi aiutarmi
Ti prego sai
[Musica]
Portami a casa
finché ci sarà
La Voce del Mare
mi abbraccerà l'istinto del sale che si
attacchino
e la tua luce che mi
[Musica]
guida
Grazie
[Musica]